i would have been 14
watching this epic skateboarding video
called public domain who scouted you for
that video how do you get into a video
like that for your first one
dude it all happened so fast but i was
you know like
i was skating for vision skateboards
vision streetwear
and and i wasn't too stoked on the
program
and they left me in las vegas at like 13
years old at a contest for real like i
flew out there they were supposed to
drive me back and then the contest ended
and they disappeared
i'm like i'm sitting in vegas with no
money no cell phones back then and i'm
literally stranded
and by the grace of god this guy comes
along he's like dude i see you need help
and
you know i got your back and i'm like
yeah what's your name and he's like my
name's mike
mike mike chernanski and this dude flew
me home from
vegas that i just met didn't know at
that time he was going to become this
very important person in my life but
he got me home so so that that point you
know my mom was a little bit
pissed off about it whatever like i did
you know
crazy to be that young and end up in a
situation like that but when i was
growing up i had
you know i was kind of an independent
little kid my mom gave me that kind of
freedom
trusting i you know would do the right
thing or
get home with you know get involved with
the right people where i wouldn't be
left in a place like you know that far
away in vegas but
anyways i had the opportunity because
8th street skateboards was starting up
right around this time
and i was hanging out at tony hawk's
house quite a bit skating his new skate
compound that he had built out in
fallbrook
and i lived kind of right by tony so i
just you know bucky was hanging out
there
bucky lasik and i started to see this
vision like wow like maybe i should
leave vision and ride for powell
but then mike ternanski you know i built
you know he flew me home from las vegas
free of charge just looking out for me
you know starts listening to me on hey
we're starting this new project
and matt hensley was my friend i grew up
with and he skated for vision
skateboards with me and he left vision
jumped on 8th street this new startup
company right yeah let me let me jump in
here i know
people hate it when i do this but to put
into perspective
paul peralta was the company that danny
was amateur for
and and tony hawk wrote for them like
all the biggest names it was the biggest
game in town
and then danny way like 13 years old
like
like all of a sudden decides i'm gonna
leave paul peralta i'm gonna quit
like the whole world is looking this
like are you [ __ ] crazy danny you're
gonna
quit pal peralta he says yep i'm gonna
quit paw patrol j i'm gonna go ride for
this company
that nobody's ever even heard of before
hasn't even been launched probably it's
called
h street they're like h street like what
even is it and why the
[ __ ] would you do that and uh and and
then
sure enough it ended up it seemed like
the most reckless move
that like career-wise that danny could
have made it ended up being
like the smartest decision ever because
at that time
h street just took over it was this this
it was yeah i mean there was like
i i had the chance to get on hc before i
got on powell
because mike planted those seeds and
when we flew home from vegas
on that flight he was like hey i'm
launching this new project with tony
magnuson
we got brian lottie mike carroll and
like and he was like pitching it and he
was like you know we're talking to matt
hensley and i'm like well okay those are
my friends i'd love to be on that
program but
the bones were yeah dude you can't like
yeah nobody's gonna shake that vision so
i i had that opportunity
and you know i jumped on on powell um
because because the
opportunity opened up for me and i chose
to ride for powell over h street
but about a year into it you know and
believe me dude i was so blown away that
i even ended up on the bones brigade
you know that video part you're talking
about the public domain video part like
stacy peralta showed up and filmed me
that day with his own camera you know
on real film like he pulled up and
filmed bucky and i that day and it was
like
i remember after the session i'm like
you know i didn't even know if i was on
pal yet like i went up there
kind of like in this transitional period
with nobody yet telling me
you're on the team or not so i shoot the
video you know we skate all day and then
i asked stacey parolt afterwards i'm
like so
am i getting on the team he's like what
do you mean you're already on dude and
i'm like
whoa i've been stressing this whole time
like did i skate well enough did i pull
this off
so it was the biggest dream come true
but after you know a year of it like
if you look at the pecking order of
people that were in line you know and i
understand like they have some
you know some some celebrity pros on the
team and a lot of good young kids on in
in the lineup you know start moving up
so like it just wasn't happening i guess
fast enough where i knew i could you
know i knew where i was at with my
skateboarding and i knew i could
i could take it to another level if i if
somebody got behind me
and pushed it further and so you know i
wasn't after a little while i wasn't
getting the things i needed to go to the
next level and mike
came you know like there was a contest
in houston texas
that was your first pro contest it was
my last amateur contest
to shut up and skate houston shut up and
skate on this in skate culture that was
like back in the day that was
like you know it was like the
underground grassroots backyard but
you know as a skate park but backyard
you know ramp style
contest mentality you know just chaos
punk rock
partying the whole deal but the you know
it was also
the one you wanted to win because it had
the most street cred
so as an amateur showing up at that
contest was everything to me and i knew
that was the contest i needed to win to
really put myself
on the map to turn pro right and i think
in the first eight street video shackle
me not they showed you winning that
contest
yeah and that was the day i started
writing a nate street board because the
story goes i
i got so desperate to go to that contest
in the ba and the bones were in
powell was like we're gonna send you and
the last second they go no we're
boycotting the contest and i'm like
boycotting what the [ __ ] does that mean
you're boycotting it what are you
boycotting i'm gonna get to this texas
promise i gotta win that you know i
gotta try and win this thing
yeah and they're like sorry we're not
going and i'm just like dude hensley
everybody's getting ready to get on
their flight
ortega all my friends i grew up to ride
for hp now my hometown friends so i'm
like feeling left out of my
my skate bubble like these are the
friends i skate with every day now
they're on a program they're doing
everything i want to be doing
so i started to get like pretty jealous
and you know it started eating me up so
i called mike up and i'm like
hey you know i know you flew me home
from the one event you didn't ask for
anything in return i appreciate that but
dude i need help getting to this houston
contest like whatever dude from me
like let me in i'm like so desperate
dude can you help me get to texas
he's like yeah we can we can make it
happen but
only if you ride for us dude
yeah dude